[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais
j'ai jamais autant déguster qu'avec toi
cette année-là
je me souviens de ce matin de décembre
il faisait froid en crever
c'était l'hiver
évidemment puisqu'on était en décembre
je me suis jamais autant Pelé que ce
matin là
[Musique]
c'était l'hiver ouais je sais je l'ai
déjà dit mais dans la chanson comment
s'adresser des débiles
on répète les trucs plusieurs fois
c'était l'hiver
en hiver comme il en existe que dans le
Bassin parisien
en banlieue est quand on habite
Pontault-Combault allez des mimosas
et que la veille il a fallu se taper le
métro jusqu'à la porte de Vincennes
attraper l'autocar conduit par un
chauffeur alcoolique qui te fait gicler
12 bornes plus loin en pleine nature et
qu'on en a encore si ça se farcira pas
de la gadoue plein les baskets pour
retrouver la fiole dégueulasse ou du
matin
[Musique]
tu ressemblais à une forte de Jérôme
Bosch
quand il se laissait
[Musique]
je me souviens
toi
moi moi
[Musique]
et tout
on a lancé sur ce terrain vague main
dans la main
tu me suis plié de pas trop serré à
cause des engelures
on s'embrassait parmi les détritus
c’était de la buée et je devrais
démonter pendant que tu chiais
je me souviens très bien
[Musique]
on ira où tu voudras quand tu voudras à
part qu'avec le loyer la bouche et les
transports à payer et le chômage qui
nous tombe sur la gueule et ben on est
dans la mer mon amour
[Musique]
et j'ai ce matin là que tu m'as envoyé
que tu étais en cloque je t'ai filé deux
claques dans le nez pour que tu fasses
attention la prochaine fois
mais comme on avait pas non plus les
moyens de s'offrir un avortement en
Suisse
peut-être
[Musique]
une dame très serviable
il nous a fait ça pour pas trop cher
[Musique]
je me
souviens aujourd'hui je suis très loin
de ce matin d'hiver
je m'en souviens comme si j'y étais
ça fera pas le tube de l'été
mais comme c'était hier
ça fera peut-être le tube de l'hiver
c'était l'hiver c'était l'hiver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]